[Music]
foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday November 3rd I'm Julie Chang
for the Wall Street Journal filling in
for Zoe Thomas
as concerns about hacking or other cyber
crime continue to grow Europe has put in
place new cyber security rules for its
aviation industry and it's not just
airlines that are being tasked with
complying with them but all those up and
down the supply chain from plane
manufacturers to weather data providers
and even Caterers here to tell us more
about these new requirements and how
companies are responding to them is wsja
pro cyber security reporter Catherine
stopp Catherine thank you for joining us
thank you for having me so Catherine
tell us some more about these new
Aviation cyber security rules what
exactly are they who would be affected
by them
so these are new cyber security rules
applying in the European Union from the
European Aviation regulator they apply
to the aviation sector and what's kind
of unique about them they're pretty
Broad in that they don't just apply to
Big Airlines and airports they apply
really across the supply chain to a lot
of smaller companies so that includes
like flight training schools aerodromes
but also these small companies that
provide services related to things like
Air Cargo or flight data
and they basically require companies to
start using software to track and
identify cyber threats that could pose a
risk to flight safety and then to
implement some kind of security measures
that actually prevent and protect
against those threats and that comes
with other kinds of governance
requirements so that companies really
need to appoint somebody internally who
will oversee their compliance with these
regulations who interact with the
regulators and things like that and do
we know why these rules were put in
place
so actually these rules have been in the
works for a number of years it's not
really because of a recent uptick or
anything that happened this year related
to cyber attacks but the people I spoke
to including at the European Aviation
regulator said that what they wanted to
prevent here is any kind of major Cyber
attack
so you know we hear cyber attacks we
hear flights obviously it worries people
How concerned should the flying public
be about potential hacking in the
aviation industry I mean is there a
danger to safety
there haven't been major cyber attacks
affecting flight safety so far
it is a nightmare scenario that people
think about and when we read headlines
or hear about cyber attacks affecting an
airline for instance that always gets
people's attention it gets people afraid
often these cyber attacks are
superficial or really low-level attacks
that affect something like a website so
last month there were cyber attacks on a
number of U.S airports websites that
actually took them down temporarily and
that was in the news about these cyber
attacks affecting airports but really
those attacks didn't have any effects
Beyond just taking down the websites in
some cases for a number of hours it was
however something that I think got a lot
of people's attention
you said that these new rules have been
in the works for a while but were there
other cyber security rules that had
already existed in this space
yes so in Europe there are cyber
security requirements for critical
infrastructure providers and that
includes a lot of airlines airports and
the requirements include reporting cyber
attacks to National regulators and
implementing some basic cyber security
protections but these new rules affect a
broader range of companies in the supply
chain that previously didn't fall under
that category of critical infrastructure
providers so that's in Europe and in the
US the Transport Security Administration
recently said they're going to introduce
some new cyber security rules for the
aviation sector and they already do have
some for airports and Airlines
and when do the new rules go into effect
they'll have to start complying by 2025.
okay so they have some time you've been
speaking with people in the aviation
industry what has their response been so
far this has definitely gotten people's
attention in the aviation industry and
they're all saying we need to start
working on complying with this really
soon not just wait until 2025 because it
could be a lot of work for us it isn't
something that's getting a huge amount
of attention outside of the aviation
industry it maybe is seen as more of a
niche technical thing but people who
work on cyber security in aviation are
definitely working on this and well
aware of what they have to do
half of the companies mentioned any
potential challenges they might come
across one of the challenges is
companies will need to set up a whole
cyber risk management system that could
mean you know buying new software
training staff on how to use it and
hiring people to actually oversee their
program make sure they're doing things
right companies in lots of different
sectors so not just Aviation are really
struggling to find cyber security staff
right now there's just a huge labor Gap
in cyber security and the people I
talked to said especially in something
really specialized like Aviation finding
people who understand
cyber security in a technical area like
Aviation could be especially difficult
so
for bigger companies this could be you
know business as usual they have maybe
big cyber security teams but for smaller
companies in particular it could be
really hard to find the right people and
also to offer them salaries to lure them
away from wherever they work currently
and with the shortage of cyber security
workers and Aviation being a very
specialized field as you mentioned do we
have a sense for how much all of this
will cost and if those costs would
trickle down to customers or Airlines
bottom lines the cost likely won't be
very significant for bigger companies
but small ones will have to think about
whether they need to hire new staff do
staff training buy software to help them
manage cyber risks this new law it
doesn't require companies go out and buy
really fancy specific new equipment
that's going to be very expensive so
it's likely not going to be
huge but especially for some of the
small companies this could be
significant for them
all right that is wsj pro cyber security
reporter Catherine stepp Catherine thank
you again for being here thank you and
that is it for today's Tech news
briefing as always you can find more
Tech stories on our website wsj.com I'm
Julie Chang for the Wall Street Journal
thank you for listening
foreign
[Music]
[Music]